we have the story from timcast Vermont
Supreme Court supports allowing illegal
non-residents to vote the Court ruled
the state's Constitution does not
require voters to be citizen to take
part in local elections by Hannah Claire
burmalow so what's going on told you I
was a writeration what's the story you
you tell me so in 2018 Montpelier and
another town whose name I can't actually
pronounce winisco I think it's
pronounced
um they passed ordinances saying anyone
can vote in our municipal election so
local elections they can't vote at the
state level they can't vote at Federal
but it means that you don't need to
legally be a resident of Vermont you
don't need to legally be an American
citizen to take part in these local
elections and they said you know it's
good it encourages people to participate
if you're being represented by these
local governments you should get to vote
and it was uh in 2020 the state
legislator approved the the they had to
change their Municipal Charters to prove
this and it was sued the RNC suit in
April of 2021 and said this is crazy
like voters shouldn't just be able to
come from anywhere and it's a
degradation to the Integrity of
Elections and it went through a couple
different uh different rulings but
basically the Supreme Court has upheld a
ruling by a lower court saying the
Vermont Constitution uh does say that
you have to be an American citizen to
vote in state elections but does not
place that requirement on Municipal
elections so this makes these two cities
in Vermont there's a bunch in Maryland
in New York City examples of places
where you don't have to be an American
citizen to participate in local
elections so I'm not a signatory on
Phil's bank accounts but I have the
right to vote where that money goes so
I'm going to vote it to me
yeah it also has non-residents so it's
it's not just illegals but non-residents
people don't even live there no so I
mean like you could be from a different
state and hop in there for a day and
vote is that what they're saying it's
like they have not defined I couldn't
find any examples of how clearly they've
defined what their residency policy is
like do you have an address if I have a
house out of state but I have like a
vacation house there I can vote in their
local so imagine a question so what's
the population of the smallest town in
Vermont that's allowing this uh it
they're similar sizes so they're
considered one of the uh the outlets I
was reading about they say that the most
diverse cities in Vermont one has 8 000
people one has seven thousand so imagine
if they have a like they have an
election and then like 14 000 people
show up yeah in a population of seven
thousand yeah that I guess that's
technically possible now that's pretty
funny yeah they have opened the doors to
just not requiring anything I mean this
is similar to the states that don't want
to require ID laws is that still does
that does that mean it's still a felony
if you vote in two places I guess it
doesn't it in these towns it doesn't
seem like they care I could not find any
specific like well you can't you know be
over here you can whatever uh it would
be a felony if if I am a person a
non-american citizen I guess I live in
this town I decide to build a little
collection if I then fill out the
ballots for state or uh Federal it would
be illegal right and so this is one of
the objections that the RNC has raised
they're saying like and similar uh
arguments came up when New York decided
to pass this they're saying like how do
you prevent voter fraud because we're
gonna have to print special ballots for
people who only are voting in the local
election and that's difficult and it's
more complicated now we have these other
ballots and we have some ballot like if
if I give you a ballot you're like hey I
live here and I want to vote and they're
like cool just only only fill out the
local spot and you don't understand you
check everything like is that your fall
is a terrible idea right to jail back to
jail it sounds like an awful idea
um I mean people representation these
people are the joke the joke I was
making about your bank account is that
if you allow non-citizens to vote they
will vote in the interests of the
non-citizens and not the citizens so if
you live in a small town that has a gold
mine within in the center of it that is
used to fund the medical care people are
going to be like oh I can vote here I
vote I get the gold I want to order
pizza they will why wouldn't they well
not even non-citizens I mean if this is
true
you know to be fair this is kind of how
elections used to work like in 1876 what
was the South Carolina like South
Carolina uh when it was going for Hayes
or whatever uh they had like what 101
percent turnout like for eligible voters
or whatever and then like in the in the
counties along the the border with
Georgia it was like twenty six hundred
percent like yeah
if it's like 101 I go now look like then
you've got an issue of check the voter
rolls how does this make sense 2600 is
outright like despite nonsense levels of
you know fun house World non-garbage
house
yeah at that point it's just like okay
we're in we're in you know Banana
Republic territory at 2600 yeah there
are some states that like specifically
say no no matter what you have to be an
American citizen to vote here so like
Ohio is one of them I feel like that
should it should not be you shouldn't
have to say it yeah it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be a a controversial take to
say the people that vote in the states
should be residents of those States they
should be citizens of those States they
should be citizens of the United States
of America just wait the next big thing
will be nativist they'll say you're a
nativist they already say it well yeah
there's already there's already a lot of
people that that if you that have
demonized the term Nationalist and
because of the association with uh you
know National Socialist or whatever you
know if you are a national nationalists
they associate you with with fascist
because fascism is always a nationalist
kind of idea they're gonna they're gonna
shift from white supremacist bigot or
whatever to nativist at some point and
they're gonna be like it's going to be
10 20 years and there's going to be a
supreme court battle and they're going
to be like these nativist begets think
that only people who live in some
location can vote on the rules and that
makes no sense well everyone gets to say
we're all equal they're going to win
people over by saying like if if you
live here in your green card holder
right like I may not be super familiar
with this but like if you're not allowed
to vote but you do live in the country
right you do have some sort of legal
status here shouldn't you be able to
participate in local elections right but
then if they also don't require you to
show any proof of residency or legal
status then there's no way to say who is
actually partaking in these elections
and at that point you don't really know
what's influencing these cities I mean
Vermont is a beautiful place obviously
it's not the population of New York City
New York City this becomes an even
bigger issue
but I to me this doesn't this feels like
common sense like you're saying like
American citizens should vote but we
know that the idea the idea that you
have to show ID when you go to vote is
actually controversial issue in a lot of
places they feel like you shouldn't have
to I want to push back on that it's not
actually controversial it is only
controversial if you listen to
politicians in from the Democrats the
average American citizen does not
believe that you should be allowed to
vote if you're not a citizen of the
state sure but they elect politicians
who are okay with the policy well they
they so you're complicit in supporting
it I have other issues with voting as
well as this one but you know the the
the idea that it is popular in the
United States I don't think that is did
you confirm this non-resident part you
sure it's just not like non-citizen I
went through the charter and I can't
find like any
the register and be on the voter rolls
right like so you can't just like show
up election day and be like oh I live in
this neighboring County or something I
mean when I read it the last time I
checked the actual uh like Charter
change they weren't requiring proof ID
right so like they are saying like you
come you vote that's cool they might
have updated it in the four year it
initially passed in 2018 right so they
might have updated it since but there is
no discussion of proving residency in
the Supreme Court case or in the
original uh
uh so it's like resident honor System
like you're supposed to be a resident
but we don't actually know if you are
yeah so you could argue if that's the
case they are technically allowing
non-residents although I think it'd be
important we fact check that one yeah
yeah I mean like I said there is no
check but I'm happy to fact check it
like what are they actually saying if
there's no check it may as well be
anyone can vote if they feel like it
they're saying that for locals elections
it doesn't matter that the Vermont
Constitution does not have a say over
local elections Vermont can regulate who
gets to vote in state elections and of
course the federal government regulates
who can vote in federal elections but
they're saying that the Vermont
government doesn't have a say over
who the municipalities are okay with
voting
no it just sounds like the end of the
country you know you see it in San
Francisco and New York they've had the
big move to allow non-citizens to vote
and it's just like then then what do you
mean it doesn't I I don't understand
why your average resident or or citizen
of these of the states are okay with it
I it it just doesn't make any sense to
me I feel like mostly it's they don't
realize I really think most people don't
pay very close attention to politics
even the people that go and vote
regularly don't pay nearly the attention
that to politics that people like us do
and so for the most part they don't know
what is what laws are being passed uh in
you know in their local areas yeah and
they always start with the safest thing
too I think they started initially with
school board so they're like well you
know if your kids they're maybe they
were born here they're American citizens
they're going to school and you might be
an illegal parent like you should be
able to have a say in your kids
education like they kind of like pull up
your heartstrings that way and then they
expand it from there and incrementalism
yeah that's how it goes yeah and then
eventually there's no country left yeah
100 that there's no there's no part of
me that doesn't believe that there there
are people motivated to change the
fundamentals structure of the United
States like and the people that say oh
no there are there are no people that
want to change the the structure of the
U.S like they're just not listening to
the writers at Vox the writers have like
there's Ian milhouser wants to get rid
of the whole Senate right there's no
reason to have a senate because
something right because there's popular
election of the of the states there's
consistently talk from people on the
left about expanding the Supreme Court
uh there's talk about getting rid of the
Electoral College these people
do not like the the structure of the
government they don't like a limited
government they don't like a government
that puts the the individual as
Sovereign these are things that
Libertarians are constantly screaming
about Luke would be here you know
putting his hand up right along with me
these people want the federal government
to have all the authority and it's
likely that they're they're in bed with
International interests it's been it's
been a move for a really long time to
strip away the local power the 17th
amendment I think was a huge mistake I
remember reading about this I think it
was uh Ben sass who called for repealing
it this is the amendment that gave uh
the the right to elect a senator to the
popular vote in the state all that does
is erode local elections and local
involvement and that was the most
destructive thing to this one of the
most destructive things in this country
because it used to be you voted in your
local elections you knew who your state
reps were they would then go the state
senators I believe would appoint a state
a senator to go to the federal
government the idea was Senators
represent States
members of Congress represent the people
yep and there was a reason for the
distinction with the popular vote now
it's just doing the same thing and
people don't even know who their local
reps are and they're like I have no idea
what that did was made it impossible or
extremely difficult to have a Convention
of states and actually work on the
Constitution amend it For The Better or
For Worse because now people don't even
know I don't know who's your vote who's
your local rep who's your State Rep you
have any idea and these the one of the
things that I find incredibly
frustrating is to your point people
don't know you and people are completely
unaware of who represents them they have
no idea uh who their congressperson is
they have no idea who their Senator is
um they don't know who the the senior
senator is the junior Senator is but
these people feel extremely motivated
every four years to go and vote they
don't know who they're voting for they
don't know why they're voting they don't
know the policies of the people that
they're voting for but every time some
celebrity gets on TV and tells them go
vote they're oh we got to get out there
and vote for what I I have no idea
they're completely ignorant I just read
a story today about how Seattle's
running out of space for all the dead
bodies from fentanyl that's gross and
then I just got mad and I'm like why is
it that all of the the major cities are
run by democrats and are collapsing are
crime ridden there there was a report I
think the Washington Post per capita
crime top 10 cities all Democrat despite
the fact that there's a there was a
couple
republican-run cities that were in the
top uh population didn't have crime or
the crime was substantially lower why is
it is because Republicans are fascists
who go around arresting everybody is it
because Democrats are extremists who at
least other prisoners there may be some
other correlating factors there I think
what uh I mean for example of the top
cities that you're mentioning I think
like most of them have like very heavy
black populations don't they like New
Orleans Detroit
the major cities uh well of the ones
that have like no not not exactly I'm
trying to think like if like San Diego
does like what's the like does San Diego
have a super heavy black population
um
this I bet it's comparable how high is
Phoenix uh
let me let me look up uh
San Diego is
it looks it's around 10 no oh it's not
was it five percent
what's the correlation
what do you mean like you're saying
these cities have so I mean it's like
the it's not it's not like totally
linear but like again these cities do
have like you know like the demographic
that commits the highest amount of
murders is like young black males if you
have a lot of that that's probably going
to be that that's that's a factor that's
a I mean does it correlate more than
having a Democrat mayor probably I would
say so because there's cities with
Democrat mayors that don't have
exorbitantly high San Diego's uh black
population 6.6 percent I don't think
that that aligns properly
no that's my point it's like it's low I
mean it's it's it's it's like half of
the national average
but
I don't think is it one of the top like
homicide cities San Diego actually has
lowest lower crime and for a while
exactly by Republican well yeah what
about not is it so so I mean perhaps the
argument is Democrats typically dominate
in the black vote and then Democrats
have garbage policies which result in
crime and releasing prisoners and things
like that you can I mean you can like I
heard you talking about this earlier Tim
the the fact that Rudy Giuliani went
into into New York City and cleaned it
up like that shows that it that right no
matter what the the racial population in
your city is because New York is you
know the it's as as mixed as it gets and
if you can go and have the right
policies and take New York City from you
know Skid Row to turning it into what is
essentially Disney World now or no five
years ago it's policy policies can solve
problems oh policy absolutely matters
and that's why I said it wasn't linear I
just said there's you know other factors
that probably correlate more I mean for
example New York City has I believe it
has more black people than like Chicago
does but Chicago is like way worse
obviously right that's why I don't I
don't know if it's the racial component
that aligns with the crime no no I'm not
saying that's the causal factor I said
it probably correlates more than having
a Democrat mayor I I disagree
I I I it feels too surface level to me
right if New York has more black people
but substantially less gun violence in
Chicago I don't see why you would draw
correlation between the racial makeup of
a city and be like Oh San Diego's got a
lower black population that explains the
crime right no doesn't no no I'm saying
because New York has a higher block it's
about does it correlate more or less
than having a Democrat mayor
yeah so so when we covered the story San
Diego had a Republican mayor and crime
was lower
okay New York has a lower black
population than Chicago and lower crime
than Chicago
so it's like I don't see the racial
connection I understand the point at the
surface level I guess if you were just
to look at it and be like oh hey look at
these things I mean so so what are the
states for example in the United States
that have like the lowest homicide rates
lowest yeah I don't know New Hampshire
Vermont very very low uh Idaho like I
mean
rural states with very few people yeah
and there and there actually is a lot of
violent crime in say West Virginia where
people like to say oh the like one thing
they bring up is oh you know these
Democrat runsees are really bad it's
like it is true like when you when you
actually like we covered this story a
couple years ago when you look at the
top crime per capita as a correlation
between cities whereby Democrats with
higher crime than cities run by
Republicans but red States in general do
do have very high rates of violent crime
too sure I mean you can always parse the
statistics out in various ways for
example the gun control organizations
they'll always take
um they'll use gun deaths instead of gun
homicides and then that way they get the
statistics well look all the Republican
states actually have higher rates of gun
death than the Democrats states do and
then they look at States they don't look
at municipalities and how those are run
so you know you can you can cherry pick
it any which way you want well so so
here's a question like why why are most
major cities Democrat no no hold on hold
on why are cities it's why are cities in
general Democrat in general you go to
West Virginia
go to any urban center no matter how
small it is for some reason Democrat
yeah I mean this is a global phenomenon
typically where like Urban centers tend
to be more uh left uh generally I think
when people congregate and they become
like sort of concentrated in certain
areas they uh they just think
differently they uh they don't have the
same day-to-day experiences people in
more rural areas historically so you
interact with your neighbor a lot more I
find you know what I mean because you
see your neighbor all the time you think
more about your neighbor I don't know if
that's correct in urban areas or rural
in urban areas for sure so I mean
because of that then you think when you
hear something saying oh well this is
better for all of us and hear the
flowery language things but if you feel
like people in urban areas interact with
your neighbor more than like people in
the in the suburbs yeah that's
completely right I think I don't know
but I feel like they ignore them
completely yeah totally but I know they
see them in person like seeing someone
and actually interacting with them is so
different it's different yeah we we've
talked to a certain degree with our
neighbors out here
in New York I lived above below side to
side and behind a person and I never saw
them never talked to them nobody
attracted once totally I don't mean
interact I just mean like you see them
in person like you see the people that's
when you see the people not that you
maybe you didn't you didn't see them at
often I'm just I'm just trying to
speculate here and come up with
something I just I I think in cities you
know Luke uh radkowski made this video
10 years ago where he was he said you
know he goes on the subway all the time
and there's millions of people coming in
and out and they never once stop and
talk to each other so he decided one day
just to talk to them and ask them you
know and then he asked about conspiracy
theories and stuff it was kind of funny
but it's a good video but he makes a
good point yeah I think in cities they
don't talk to each other yeah I don't
mean I don't mean talk I mean like
literally just literally see them I
don't think that's the case I can't tell
you what my neighbors looked like I can
tell you all my neighbors out here look
like yeah like true to a certain degree
like we have to talk to him in the city
like I said I was in an apartment above
someone below someone had two apartments
to the side an apartment behind me it
was you got you got the the the the door
and there's a stairwell and then there's
apartments all around it totally and
then there's one corner corner and then
behind I don't I I I can't tell you what
they look like yeah true I mean you
definitely have more community in small
towns definitely because like that's
just reality you have to rely on your
community in a small town you're just
more likely to know who your cops are
right exactly I'm just trying to again
maybe that's some kind of Reason well
the the one thing about cities is is
cities do attract people that want to be
in cities like you hear the stories all
the time about kids that leave their
small town to go to the big city but
there there are kids that are like I
don't want to go to the big city I like
it like you definitely have temperaments
people that have a temperament that is
is more uh more conducive to wanting to
live in an urban area versus someone
that wants to live in a rural area and
then of course you do have a certain
amount of people that would go to a city
and be like this is not for me vice
versa but I think that the people that
that have the uh that are inclined to go
to cities and and seek out that kind of
Lifestyle probably have the same
inclination to be like oh I think that
the government should provide services
and and Etc things like that I don't
know I'm just trying to figure out like
like we asked like why is it that why is
the democrators do you have a do you
have a reason maybe well I'll tell you
this Democrat policy I think leads to
higher crime rates yeah and maybe it's
just
they're really good at scaring people
into falling in line and joining the
cult I guess yeah earlier about that how
it's a school to just go and vote
because everyone tells them to go when
you say you know there's a meteorologist
in New York Fox News got beaten up by a
bunch of teenagers yeah right in some
way yeah and they and the police said
we're not going to arrest or charge them
because they were 15 and 17 or whatever
well they said it would be a misdemeanor
and it's like how is it a misdemeanor
when this guy has like very visible
marks from being brutally assaulted
that's crazy because of their ages they
weren't charged they were released to
the parents so these are the policies
that Democrats enact uh look I get it
man I don't like cash bail I think we
need prison reform I think we need more
place accountability but like just
releasing criminals doesn't seem to make
sense no the the options that have been
brought you know the ideas that have
been have been brought up uh to deal
with the over criminalization maybe you
call it in the U.S they're not good
ideas like nobody like the idea of
getting rid of the police totally well
it's a terrible idea because they're
talking about replacing them with with
social workers that are completely and
totally incapable of securing an area to
try to deal with whatever's going on I
think part of it is like this idea like
with the meteorologists that well their
kids we don't want to mark them with
this records or listen to their parents
like I don't necessarily agree with that
but like there are a lot of places Rural
and not that try to prevent
children especially from being unfairly
punished for crimes that like if you
were an adult committed would be pretty
serious so like I wrote this article
last week about a 18 year old with age
of 16 murdered four family members in
Cold Blood execution style in West
Virginia and he will be eligible he's
been given life in prison but because of
a mercy rule in West Virginia it because
he committed the crimes the minor he's
eligible for for parole in in 15 years
so is that because he deserves it is
that because his crime is Justified is
that because like at 16 he doesn't
understand the consequences like you're
saying these kids are 15 and 17. if you
got caught shoplifting I could see
releasing to your parents if you leave
physical marks on someone like you can
see that that crime is more serious but
I think you sell it like if you're
someone who lives in an area that is
affected by crime rural or not being
able to say like
yeah this person uh when you when you
get a criminal record at an early age
and it follows you for the rest of life
you are basically on a downward spiral
like it's very difficult to overcome
that I think we understand why this
stuff sells but in practical application
it doesn't always
serve the communities the best and
really understand the differences
between major cities is hard because we
don't have a great example of a direct
comparison a city that has high violence
and is run by a Republican mayor and a
city that has high values similar
population run by democrats yeah now I
think about Montreal for instance
because they're extremely racially and
ethnically diverse and they don't have
nearly the level of crime of Chicago
like what is wrong with Chicago true I
think it's the corruption I think
Chicago is a mob town you know a lot of
people are talking about the gang
bangers and all that stuff and and and
like the south side and the black
community and I'm like yeah no I hear
you man because I grew up down there but
you gotta understand the cops are
crooked as they come the cops would
kidnap and torture people when I was
like in my lifetime you know what I mean
so it's like the crime exists it just
exists in different ways something's
going on in Chicago where everybody's
just kind of a dick like not not
everybody obviously you know I love my
Chicago family but um a lot of a lot of
bad stuff like just think about all the
the the early 1900s go to go to
Midlothian Turnpike if you want to see
where apparently that's where Capone
dumped all the bodies so you've had a
history of corrupt government the past
few Governors all going to prison you
have gang violence sums up with Chicago
I mean Baltimore is really bad too don't
be wrong Baltimore has a lot of crime
and uh so people want to look at the
surface level and they see a racial
component I assume there's a lot of
crime or there's corruption in Baltimore
but it doesn't I don't have the same uh
the same association with corruption
that I do with with Chicago for sure
Chicago you think you think the racial
component plays like no role whatsoever
I mean clearly we know that like it's a
surface level thing well you don't you
don't think there's like a big
difference as far as like different
groups the way they like commit homicide
like the amounts and like the rates I
don't think the race is the issue I'm
not saying I'm just saying like it's not
about it the race itself being the issue
it's that like the the actual it's just
the fact that this group has a higher
rate of homicide sure sure yeah and then
you you take into consideration
different societal factors
it's H2 like no no one is saying like 70
year old uh you know black people are
committing homicides at the same rate as
like 15 or like like 20 year old
Hispanic people like obviously not the
the challenge is you obviously have I
did I I did a documentary I talk about
it periodically about Pruitt I go
Ferguson the riots why people are so
angry why there's crime the way it is
and what ends up happening is I'll have
a conversation with someone and they'll
say exactly what you did they'll be like
oh but yeah but you know young black men
are the most are the high the higher
highest demographic when it comes to
murder and stuff and it's like in
Chicago it's very different in New York
New York has a much much lower crime
rate though the crime still does exist
but no but that that difference still
exists there as well right right and so
what it is is this is the challenge of
racism
is that people will will be like I'm
trying to figure out a pattern here and
I've noticed these two people look
different so I had a conversation with a
guy about uh race realism and he was
mentioning oh well you know Somalians
have low IQs and I was like Somalia a
country in in decades of Civil War and
strife and famine and drought and
constant you know like you're you're
well yeah but and then they would make
the argument that even people who've
left and I'm like right dude look you go
back three generations of a country
being destroyed or or people coming from
a place where there's limited nutrients
you're going to have that go down the
line genetics epigenetics or whatever I
don't think that we're solving the
problem by comparing a black guy from
Haiti to you know a black guy from the
South Bronx I think there's you can
probably I think there's genetic nature
versus nurture components and everything
so there's there's probably something to
be said for looking at an individual and
making determination like if you were to
say white people tend to be taller I'd
say Yeah in Scandinavia if you were to
say Asian people tend to be shorter I'd
be like right we know these things exist
but I don't think when we're trying to
get to the root of social problems it's
solved by being like well I happen to
notice the racial components in crime
and I'm like yeah and I also noticed the
voting patterns and I also noticed
they're releasing people from prisons in
these cities and so I kind of feel like
I understand there's a nature versus
nurture argument I kind of think it's in
the middle I think if we're actually
going to solve these problems we need to
just commonly say you know I don't think
the surface level racial component is
actually the the a strong enough
correlation or the cause of the problem
I think it could be solved if we didn't
have lunatic leftist policy but why do
you think it is that in New York City
for example when it comes to the
shootings and the murders it's almost
always every year over 93 percent uh
Black and Hispanic oh man this is a much
longer conversation we should probably
have in the members only because it's
going to take sure like we're seven
minutes past uh the doing a super chats
but I think a large component obviously
has to do with why is it that Nigerian
immigrants don't have these levels of
crime and are very successful with
higher salaries but people born in
America who are black we notice these
Trends I think it might have something
to do with slavery the history of of
racial politics in this country I think
that you said you mentioned racial
politics I think that the the whole idea
of like uh young black people that that
study hard and they get told they're
acting white I think there's a stigma
that or at least I hear there's a stigma
in the black community about let's let's
try to Excel and they get told oh you're
acting white and blah blah so it's
probably something that's we gotta go we
gotta go super chats but we'll we'll
talk about this we'll get into a lot
more of the stuff in the members only
show
um not to say that I would talk about on
YouTube it's just that we're seven
minutes past when we like to start and
do super chats and get to people
questions so go to Tim guest.com become
a member smash that like button click
that join us button at timcast.com and
then we'll carry on this conversation
and we'll go into great detail as calmly
and reasonably as we want of course look
man there's a lot of people who just
don't care about any arguments and I I
I'm not a fan of I'm not a fan of any
argument that is tribal purely you can't
convince me I won't listen to you okay
dude then we're not having a
conversation if you want to have a
conversation hang out with us at
timcast.com we may disagree but that's
that's the point thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and because become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time